[Music]
when the confining routines of normality
waver were dissolve when there's an
earthquake you know and there's a flood
when there's some natural disaster that
sweeps away the structures of society
it's not what one might expect doggy-dog
looting and chaos and the strong preying
on the weak ah
it's people getting together to take
care of each other this natural altruism
and community and solidarity emerges and
you realize that it's been repressed all
the time by our systems and ideologies
of separation but it's always laying
there waiting for its moment to come
back and this is such a moment it's
showing us the future we could go to a
future where we're all in this together
where we understand that your well-being
and my well-being are connected and even
the well-being of other creatures and
that health and happiness and even real
wealth does not and cannot exist in
isolation but only in community and so
we can say yeah enough of this
trajectory of separation now is the time
to rejoin the community of humanity and
then rejoin the community of life that's
the the crossroads that we're at right
now that's Charles Eisenstein and this
is the retro podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast hey everybody how
you guys doing what's happening my name
is rich roll I'm your host welcome to
the podcast
okay so a lot is happening right now at
the risk of overstating the obvious the
world is truly enduring a surreal moment
unlike anything I think any of us have
ever previously experienced jobs are
disappearing many are very sick some
have perished most people are scared our
movements are restricted the streets are
empty and there is no business as usual
for many there is no business at all and
if you're like me quarantined in your
home physically separated from friends
and loved ones wondering if and when you
two may fall ill trying to maintain
sanity amidst all of this struggling to
make sense of it all endeavoring to
control the few controllables perhaps
attempting to also identify the
opportunity performing an inventory of
your life investing in what is working
discarding what's not hopefully
connecting with a little bit of
gratitude without minimizing the extreme
hardship that most are currently facing
I think it is important to also
recognize this rare moment as something
extraordinary that we as individual
members of a global collective are being
delivered an opportunity to recognize
the fallacy of separateness an
opportunity to deconstruct this
long-held idea that in so many ways has
led us astray that we exist independent
of each other outside of and exempt from
the living breathing biosphere that we
inhabit as both participants and as
guests and if there's a silver lining in
any of this and I believe there is
it's that we're being marshaled to
embrace with humility that we are but a
very small part of a much greater whole
and that it is now incumbent upon us to
rethink to reimagine and and recreate
the story we tell ourselves about who we
are and who we aspire to be in so many
ways this is like an initiation a reset
a call to embrace our inherent divinity
and an innate interconnectedness as
spiritual beings having a human
experience in divine relationship with
not only ourselves but with every living
thing an opportunity to expand our
awareness to elevate our consciousness
and chart a more compassionate and
sustainable and community-based normal
going forward
today's guest one of the deepest
integrative thinkers active today is to
my mind at least an important and
integral voice in this very conversation
a speaker a writer and a social
philosopher focusing on themes of human
cultural evolution economics and
consciousness Charles Eisenstein is the
author of several books most recently
climate a new story as well as sacred
economics the more beautiful world our
hearts know is possible and the ascent
of humanity a graduate of Yale
University where he acquired degrees in
both mathematics and philosophy Charles
is a counterculture intellectual a
proponent of alternative political and
economic narratives that combined
ecology biology philosophy and
spirituality to challenge our current
system you can find his essays videos
and courses at Charles Eisenstein org
and he hosts a podcast entitled a new
and ancient story in the vein of my
exchanges with dr. Jacque Bush this is
an incredibly deep thoughtful and
time's metaphysical conversation I'm
honored to share it and it's coming up
in a few but first we are brought to you
today by fully empowering your work and
life with the best standing desks chairs
and ergonomic furniture to keep you
moving engaged and loving how you feel
at work you guys have heard me talk many
times about how much I love my Jarvis
standing desk
the Aloha saddle chairs in my podcast
studio my guests love them and right now
we're in the middle of doing a studio
remodel
I'm also upgrading my container office
so I just got a few new items a couple
of their stainless steel sidekick file
cabinets that double as comfortable
seats stools plus this awesome beam led
desk lamp it's super dope I love all of
their stuff and in addition to just
amazingly cool modern office furnishings
I will tell you that I really do love
supporting fully and primarily because
of their ethos I was on the phone with
them the other day and they were telling
me about how they are navigating this
moment as a corporate culture and what
came across so clear is this honest
commitment that they've made to really
show up right now in this unique
environment to help people and
businesses across the US Canada and
Europe acclimate to make this transition
to working from home easy comfortable
convenient and affordable sequestration
has required many of us to adapt and as
somebody who's been working from home
for many years I've learned that it's
really key to mindfully create a
workspace that not only inspires you but
supports you and your back of course and
also provides you with the freedom to
move and adjust posture so you can feel
engaged while you work from home fully
checks all the boxes it's a B Corp
everything they make is environmentally
friendly ethically manufactured and
delivered straight to your door if
you're giving your home office a
makeover or come on let's be real
setting up office in the living room
fully is here for you if you need help
transitioning your team or
want to take advantage of their
introductory offer for our listeners
visit fully calm slash rich roll that's
fu ll why.com slash rich roll fully
everything you need to find your work
flow okay
recognizing the delicacy of this moment
I've been very careful about who I
invite on the show to discuss it because
the pandemic has cast this cosmic panic
I really don't want to amplify that
aspect of it but I also don't feel it's
appropriate to deliver a handful of
conjectural optimism I don't hold myself
out as knowing exactly what is happening
I don't think any of us do I can't give
you a prediction or a pithy prescription
but what I can offer is a perception and
some perhaps perspective last week I
devoured a recent essay by Charles
entitled the coronation and I found it
to be one of if not the most insightful
and intelligent long reads on how to
think expansively about our current
moment and I highly suggest you give it
a read I'll link it in the show notes of
course it's a piece that has stayed with
me I found myself going back to it a
couple times and although Charles and I
had previously been discussing getting
together this summer for an in-person
podcast it's this article this long read
that inspired me to seek him out for
today's show so this is a conversation
about many things it's about completely
redefining our definition of normal
leveraging this experience to unite and
reinvent our society it's about asking
questions it's about challenging the
dominant narrative and our cognitive
biases and it's about taking a hard look
at our institutional failures and the
systems that perpetuate them but more
than anything this is about standing in
our fear wading through the muddy waters
of media calamity conspiracy theories
and fake news
- instead listen and feel the quiet
excitement that change is actualizing
without minimizing the severity of what
is and what is to come this truly is our
opportunity to create a new world and
may Charles Eisenstein be our gentle
steward thank you for doing this I'm a
longtime follower and admirer of your
work and I've wanted to meet you for
some time we began an email exchange
some months ago about trying to align
our schedules to podcast during your
next visit to LA that was looking like
July yeah and then I read your latest
piece the coronation and it really moved
me and I decided that now is the time I
think that your voice is much needed in
this unprecedented and precarious moment
of fear uncertainty anxiety and also
opportunity and I think it's also fair
to say that you're pretty ideally
perfectly situated to speak to this
calamity with a certain wisdom and
breadth and perspective as from my
perspective this situation kind of
weaves into keen focus and intersects so
perfectly with so many of the themes and
the ideas that you so eloquently speak
to and write about from our increased
separation from self and others in
nature and our divinity to the ills and
and the myopia of our economic and
political systems and our inability to
kind of problem-solve from a perspective
that transcends the polarization and the
shared assumptions and kind of
entrenched paradigms that were currently
sitting in so the reason and the kind of
moment for this podcast is really to
talk about what's happening now from
your perspective and how you're thinking
about this collective experience that
we're all enduring wow that's a amazing
summary I couldn't have done it better
myself
yeah for years and years I've been
writing about what systems change
actually looks like and how it
corresponds to something even deeper
that you might call narrative change or
mythology change and then how that also
interpenetrates our own psychology
because we're not just these discrete
individuals floating through a world but
the world becomes us and we become the
world so when the system changes and or
when when it when it falls apart like is
seems to be happening now then we fall
apart in some way like or at least we
get this vertigo that Who am I
now when the reinforcing circumstances
of my life disappear and who I've been
how I've been thinking how I've been
speaking what I've been doing doesn't
really make sense anymore Who am I now
mm-hmm and and it's like disorienting
but also in a way empowering because it
reminds us that the things that we took
for granted both externally on a social
political level but also in our own
lives
maybe those are coming up as conscious
choices that had once been
unconscious programs so there's a
certain ascension into a seat of if not
power at least volition at least
choosing now like people talk about a
reset or a pause in normality which
gives us the opportunity to even ask do
we want to go back to normal
mm-hmm like we were stuck in normal
generations of revolutionaries and
people who wanted to make change social
reformers have been getting burnt out
pretty frustrated because no matter how
hard their efforts nothing really seems
to be changed and we're all to some
extent stuck in a system that no one
actually loves no one thinks I mean look
at members of Congress like how many of
them would say yeah I think Congress is
really working well this system is good
so so now it's like this deliverance not
that it's going to automatically
uh sure in a more beautiful world but at
least it gives us this moment of choice
and we ask do we even want to go back to
normal
and if not what is possible if such a
big change is possible now what's
possible mm-hmm yeah it is interesting I
feel like there's a a battle between
this sense of enhanced volition or
agency as you mentioned but also a
countervailing force of loss of control
or a lack of agency where you know we're
seeing forces beyond ourselves taking
the reins of power and we're seeing you
know diminished liberties and a sense of
disempowerment with an inability to kind
of go about our daily lives and that's
creating at least in my own experience
like this sort of emotional storm as to
what to do next I'm certainly seizing
the opportunity and the gift inherent in
the pause to reflect and think more
deeply about the choices that I've made
and better choices that I could make and
also to think you know more broadly
about the systems at play and trying to
imagine a better system
for the future and it is a war between
an optimistic voice and a pessimistic
voice about what is to come because on
some level there is a light dusting of
existential crisis about this but at
some point it will pass and we will you
know be allowed to you know reenter the
world and everybody's talking about a
new normal it's unclear what that new
normal is or whether there ever wasn't
normal to begin with and my fear is that
people will be in a rush to resume
business as usual and we will have
missed the opportunity to set in motion
you know the ideas that we're all
thinking about right now to craft a
better more sustainable kinder gentler
world yeah on a very immediate level we
are much less free and much less in
choice than we ever have been we can
only you
leave the house for things that the
government deems are essential and those
things are the things that the most
Orthodox conventional mindset as applied
not only to health but to what's
important in life
validate so if you want to take care of
your health by going to the chiropractor
or the acupuncturist or the herbalist or
the yoga class or anything like that the
value of those things is not recognized
by standard virology or by the political
authorities so those are totally off the
table mm-hmm all you're allowed to do
are the most conventional Orthodox
things so this restriction of our choice
and the limitation of things we've taken
for granted freedom of assembly even to
some extent freedom of speech you know
the internet censorship has ramped up to
protect people from what the authorities
deemed to be misinformation or
disinformation and I lost the beginning
of that sentence but just saying that
our freedom is restricted like never
before but in a way it's doing us a
favor by showing us where we've been
going anyway mm-hmm every response to
kovat 19 is a continuation or an
intensification of something that was
already happening in society social
distancing people are congregating less
and less in public spaces and living
more and more online the migration of
commerce onto the Internet the migration
of Education onto online forums the
restriction of civil liberties I mean
this has been happening the monitoring
of you're aware abouts at all times the
regime of paranoia about germs and I'm
venturing into somewhat on
the docks territory here but a few years
ago there was an article III cited it in
my essay about the dangers of excessive
hygiene I think that article was titled
is is hygiene making us sick because our
health and especially the functioning of
our immune systems depends on constant
interaction with the world of life the
microbial world
the viral world and when we're cut off
from that and we are in isolation then
we lose the integrity and robustness of
our immune system and our body ecology
in the same way that when we're cut off
from social interaction we lose the
robustness of a connected self that's
embedded in community mmm-hmm and so
like so all these trends are reaching
this extreme to the point where you know
we could imagine never going back to
normal
like a lot of people are doing just fine
in measurable ways living at home never
going outside getting everything
delivered to their door and we could
imagine continuing this so that robots
are doing their deliveries and anytime
you are in public you're wearing a mask
and protective gear and the handshake
and the hug are relegated to the history
books mm-hmm because why because we're
too afraid now yeah that's a rather
depressing and dystopian extrapolation I
think what we're experiencing right now
and you know to the point about our
receptivity to our natural environments
the separation you know when you look at
it in a macro sense the additional
hygiene the isolation the separation
ultimately you know when you when you
cast it out into the future creates a
greater threat to our ability to weather
a future pandemic because we've become
so insulated and separated from the
natural environment and preventing
ourselves from developing the natural
immunities that come with being immersed
in
more interconnected that's right and so
the response to that future pandemic
would be an even tighter regime of
control mm-hmm and this is the net
perpetuate deeper patterns of our
civilization is that our reflexive
response to a crisis is to impose and
extend our control over the world and
when that generates further crises we
respond by extending even more control
over the world mm-hmm it's it's an
addiction pattern and we see it played
out in every realm as applied to school
shootings as applied to terrorism you
know foreign policy agriculture medicine
you know and say in agriculture when the
pesticides and herbicides and chemical
fertilizers destroy the soil leaving
crops even more susceptible to disease
than we develop even new more powerful
pesticides yeah it is interesting it
belies our hubris in the sense that we
we can't seem to learn our lesson from
the great history of failed attempts at
control history is littered with these
wars on various forms of illness whether
it's pestilence or terrorism or drugs
that have not reaped the benefits that
have been promised and yet we seem to
continue to resort back to control as
the default mechanism for how we're
gonna navigate you know the next crisis
that befall us yeah it's part of a very
deep myth that I would say defines our
civilization which is I call it the myth
of ascent or the myth of technological
utopia that basically says we started
out as these superstitious primitive
helpless ignorant creatures at the mercy
of natural forces and barely surviving
amidst all the competition in the
natural world but thanks to our big
brains we developed science and
technology and gradually century by
century exerted more
dominance over the world mm-hmm and
someday this grand project will be
complete when science develops a theory
of everything when nanotechnology and
genetic engineering allows us to extend
our control down to the nano level then
we will be completely safe and perhaps
even win victory over death itself and
attain to immortality and become the
gods become gods and we're getting there
mm-hmm you know we can already do things
that only the gods used to be able to do
like communicate instantaneously we're
vast distances and fly through the air
and build mountains called skyscrapers
you know and change the course of rivers
and and soon we're gonna solve
everything and engineer all of our
problems out of existence and this has
been the promise that probably reached
its heyday mid 20th century that science
was gonna conquer all and surely by the
year 2000 we would have conquered all
diseases mm-hmm this ambition you know
the this promise of technological and
social utopia is 20 years overdue and
people are getting angry when they
realized that rather than life getting
better and better by each generation
it's getting in a lot of ways worse and
worse are people healthier now and
happier than they were a generation ago
not according to the depression
statistics or the obesity or addiction
or suicide anxiety statistics even
longevity is starting to decline now so
mm-hmm
what do we do about it gods without the
wisdom wielding great power but without
the adequate you know amount of
information or foresight to make the
best decisions I suppose and also like
there may be inherent limitations to the
kind of power that we have gained I'm
not saying that it's bad and that we
should undo civilization and give up the
life-saving miracles that modern
medicine has achieved
but we tend to apply what we're really
good at outside of its proper domain
mm-hmm and try to you know we end up
usurping the sovereignty of other ways
of engaging the world that are not about
imposing domination and imposing force
on the world this is getting super
philosophical and I'm not sure how I
know that's great okay this is why this
is why I'm dialing you up all right I
want you to go as deep as you want to go
so okay I was saying like the ultimate
triumph the ultimate conquest would be
to conquer death itself then we would
have finally ascended over nature this
ambition of ascent has a technological
rendition where we end up in space you
know and uploading our consciousness to
computers and things like that and it
also has a spiritual rendition which
sees spiritual progress analogously to
technological progress as being more and
more separate from the Earth from the
world and we see the same ambition
register in socio-economic terms where
the highest status professions are the
ones that are further separated from the
soil mm-hmm the ones that deal in
abstractions the abstractions of
financial derivatives or scientific
equations those are the highest status
and the applied scientist has a little
less status and the engineer even less
and the plumber even less and at the
bottom is the peasant mm-hmm and that's
how it's been for thousands of years and
although there is a revolution in our
stories right now that is celebrating
finally the farmer and wishing to
reintegrate with materiality and the
soil and the earth so this is the
turning that I've been serving my whole
life and and so yeah like we see the
signs of a new story but it seems like
the Cova 19 pandemic is showing us the
old story in its most extreme form one
way that it's showing us that is
by revealing what price we pay to
prolong life and minimize risk at all
costs that's this shadow of the attempt
to conquer death which of course well I
would I believe we'll never succeed but
if we can't conquer it at least we deny
it mm-hmm
we hide it with euphemisms and we pursue
endless youth and money and property
which gives us the illusion that we're
gonna survive forever so many ways that
our culture denies and hides death and
and one of those ways is medical where
the entire medical system is geared
toward saving lives preventing deaths
and I'm not being heartless here I like
being alive I want my loved ones to be
alive my mother is in her late 70s and
frail if she got covered she would
almost certainly pass away
but is that the most important value to
live as long as possible what do we
sacrifice when we pursue that or even
just in our normal lives what do we
sacrifice when we put safety first above
all else mm-hmm yeah in the article you
you present this thought experiment
about you know really pushing the
boundaries of the precautions that we're
taking you know at what point does it
become no longer socially acceptable to
isolate if we're doing it to save a
million lives if we're doing it to save
a hundred thousand lives or if we're
doing it solely to save Charles's life
or his mother's life should all of
society be sequestered for that purpose
alone and somewhere in between rests the
value that we will socially agree upon
right but beneath it all is a
conversation about the manner in which
our culture whitewashes death this death
denial that you speak about and our
inability to kind of be comfortable
confronting that reality and I feel like
Co vyd puts this in front of us and
exposes our fears around death like you
qualify it as a rehab intervention that
breaks the addictive hold of normality
and on some level part of that addiction
is our addiction to this denial that
ultimately you know we will escape death
even though we intellectually understand
that we're going to die I think all of
us hold in the back of our minds some
sense that perhaps we're gonna find a
way out of that right that's what I'm
talking about there are conflicting
values here and I don't think there's a
simple formula that can resolve these
conflicting values like yeah I mean you
could say Charles how dare you say that
maybe we shouldn't socially isolate when
that could cause an extra 5,000 deaths
or 10,000 or 50,000 deaths and that
could be your mother I mean you know
don't be so heartless these are precious
lives but there are more important
things than living as long as possible
there's some
that you might call living as
beautifully as possible living a good
life living the right life that is hard
to recognize when we are immersed in a
quantitative mindset it's hard to value
those things numerically it's hard to
fit them into costs and benefits and
when the society in general I mean this
goes all the way down to who we know
ourselves to be who we think ourselves
to be the reigning ideology of
civilization says that we are separate
individuals we are separate selves which
means that when you die that's total
annihilation that's the ultimate
catastrophe so of course you want to
prolong your life but if we understand
ourselves as not just limited to a skin
encapsulated ego but as inter-relational
inter beings then death takes on a very
different resonance and prolonging the
life of the separate self is no longer
the highest priority and this is
something people recognize on a gut
level I mean every time you go to a
music festival or get in a car or go
rock climbing for God's sake or do
anything that is fun or that pushes your
boundaries that challenges your limits
that puts you into an uncertain unknown
realm then you are in fact trading
safety and security and risk
minimization for a fuller experience of
life this is a trade-off that different
people resolve in different ways I mean
some people err more on the side of
safety and caution and others like to
take risks but I don't think that
there's a clear formula to make that
determination mm-hmm our culture over my
lifetime has gone more and more and more
toward safety toward risk minimization
and the price has been a impoverished
experience of life to the point where
children are no longer playing outside
with each other I mean this did not just
start with kovat for my whole life I've
seen a the dwindling of that
quintessential pack of kids outside
playing cops and robbers playing in the
world of the imagination I know I would
agree without a hundred percent I mean I
think we're about the same age and the
era of you know leaving your house and
riding your bike all day and coming home
at dinner
who would would get you you know in
trouble with child services in this day
and age which right you know leaves me
despairing I mean this is something that
Jonathan Hite talks about all the time
and one of the things that he also
speaks to I mean it's basically in a
broader sense it's it's another example
of enhanced separation we're separating
ourselves more and more from each other
and from our natural environments and
we're doing this now to our children out
of a you know I guess you could contend
laudable concern for their well-being
but at the same time much at their peril
and you know Jonathan also talks about
the kind of end of shared experiences
you know he speaks to 911 being the last
of our collective communal shared
experiences because now by dint of
technology everything is channeled based
on our silos and those silos are
separated and when it comes to kovat 19
I think it's you know not too far off to
say that there are two pandemics or
perhaps more there's the pandemic that
that you'll experience if you're
watching CNN and there's a different
pandemic if you're watching Fox News
there's the pandemic that's visiting us
in our homes and in our works but I
don't know despite you know you can go
on social media and see people in Italy
singing from their balconies and and we
can see technology being leveraged to
you know get people masks from the
private sector there
certainly positive aspects to this but
at the same time our experiences are
becoming more and more tribe dependent
and that is you know an exacerbation of
this separation that you speak to yes I
think that this tribalism and social and
political polarization is itself a
symptom as well as a cause of separation
because when place based communities
break down and when we're no longer held
in a web of stories and relationships to
the people around us and to the nature
around us then we are our identity which
depends on relationships shrinks and we
don't know who we are anymore so then
when a political narrative comes along
along with an in-group that says here's
who you are and the price of admission
to join the club is to display certain
opinions then people are very vulnerable
to that and they get to get at least
some identity through political
identification and then you know that
identification is constantly reinforced
in that particular silo or echo chamber
and it says here's the way the world is
here's who you are in that world
here's what's important here's how to do
this here are the good guys
here are the bad guys so we're really
susceptible to that especially the
overlay template of good guys and bad
guys and that way of seeing the world is
one of the strands of DNA of our
civilization one of the deep programs
that the world is composed of good and
bad and that progress means overcoming
the bad with the good goes back
thousands of years overcoming the
barbarians expanding the domestic realm
conquering the wild conquering the
beasts draining the wetlands that was
being done 5,000 years ago cutting down
the forests tilling the soil
straightening the rivers
like imposing order on to chaos
overcoming every resistance and then
translating into the mentality of war
and into medicine - like we are very
comfortable as a culture with Kovan 19
in a way because it's something we can
understand there's a bad guy making a
sick and so we are we mobilize on every
level from the political authorities
down all the way to individual citizens
self isolating we mobilize because we
know what to do
in contrast stark contrast to the silent
epidemics that are killing way more
people than covered 90 never will such
as autoimmunity such as obesity such as
addiction we don't there's no enemy to
fight for these epidemics mm-hmm there's
nothing there's no pathogen there's
nothing to conquer but they're the cause
lies within ourselves lies within our
society there's nothing to fight so our
customary approach to change which is
domination find a bad guy and destroy it
doesn't work and and you can see just
this tendency to look for a bad guy and
this almost nostalgic wish that there
were a identifiable bad guy in American
foreign policy where the Soviet Union I
mean now those were the good old days
you know evil was evil good was good and
we knew what it was and ever since then
the foreign policy establishment has
been groping around for a new bad guy
his llama terror was it for a while you
know after 9/11 okay that was scary for
a while but after 20 years of endless
war after that people stopped being
scared so then they resurrected Russia
you know and Vladimir Putin as the new
bad guy but aside from the talking heads
on TV no one's actually terrified of
flat amir putin not the way that we were
you and i were terrified of the soviet
union when we were kids you know mhm
do you remember like the big map with
the soviet union three times the size of
america
bristling with missiles you know the
Iron Curtain the Gulag Archipelago that
was scary
yeah it was and do you remember the
movie the day after
yeah when we were kids you have a super
family I have a very vivid memory of
being you know quite terrified about
that and yet here we are with an
identifiable enemy that we actually are
attempting to exert control over via
domination Dominion yeah and yet we're
still unable to completely unify in fact
I'm you know I'm seeing a more fractured
culture around how to address this
problem
then perhaps we would have seen even a
few decades prior yeah people do not
trust Authority not nearly as much as
they did twenty years ago I think part
of the reason is that our new happy
lives to take a line from Orwell that
were promised to us have not
materialized even as we've done as we
were told
mmm we haven't gotten healthier and
healthier despite getting all of our
checkups and going to the doctor and
doing as we've been told so and not to
mention you know income inequality and
things like that
normal hasn't been working and there is
a lot of latent anger fury I think
especially among the working classes
that makes them unwilling to really
believe what the authorities are telling
us and I like I'm not sure if I believe
it you know I've gone into all of the
conspiracy theories and all of the
alternative narratives and the
questioning of I mean it just it's it's
a rabbit hole
it's a warren of rabbit holes when you
look into you know are that many people
dying well you know if someone dies and
there's de textbook Ovid then and
subscribe to Cove it even though they
would have been dying of something else
and the tests the PCR tests are not even
reliable because they don't measure
viral load and etc etc and I mean
there's just it's just like this this
thicket of conflicting yeah I mean they
yeah there's no end to the you know
conspiracy theory rabbit hole when it
comes
- this for sure but one of the things
that I thought was super interesting in
your piece was that whether or not any
of these theories you know hold merit is
irrelevant because they represent this
unconscious systemic tilt toward ever
increasing control in other words there
doesn't need to be an Illuminati or some
brain trust that's pulling you know
that's some puppet master who's
controlling all this but our systems are
set up to lean in this direction right
and so I thought you know if you could
expound upon that because I found that
to be very interesting yeah I mean all
that's necessary for all of this to
happen is to have a predisposition
toward thinking that disease is caused
by pathogens and systems set in place
that can respond to that so there's the
preparation there's the mindset there's
the opportunity to act on that I used
the metaphor of it's a kind of a tired
cliché but if all you have is a hammer
then everything looks like a nail
mm-hmm to the point where you might be I
mean maybe it's maybe it is a nail maybe
this is a straightforward case of a
dangerous pathogen and everything we're
doing is appropriate to protect
ourselves and to conquer it
but if it weren't a nail we wouldn't
know that because of the way that the
media is working because of the built-in
biases of the medical system in in the
essay I go into a little bit into what's
known as terrain theory exemplified by
the meme that I saw which is your fish
is sick germ theory isolate the fish
terrain Theory clean the tank mmm-hmm so
many diseases can be seen as as symptoms
where or the the infectious agent can be
seen as symptoms of a condition that
makes you susceptible to that infection
and in some schools of thought it's
actually good for you to get colds and
flus occasionally because it kind of
cleans out your system it's like this
accelerated processing of stored up
metabolic wastes and toxins and things
like that and I'm throwing unscientific
terms around very carelessly here but
metaphorically like the fever you know
burning off the waste the mucus
discharging the junk you know and in
some schools of thought even the classic
childhood diseases measles mumps and
chickenpox put the child through a kind
of initiation for example a camera which
one it is but one of them is like after
you've gone through that illness and
you've gotten better by yourself
basically no one can really do anything
for you
it imparts to the child this confidence
I can meet a challenge I can do this and
it's even conceivable that viral
diseases especially transmitted DNA into
our genome and are a way for genetic
information to spread much more rapidly
than standard Darwinian or Mendelian
mechanisms would allow because and this
gets like this is a whole nother rabbit
hole but viruses are extremely similar
to extracellular vesicles that cells
secrete or emit to signal each other and
to transmit genetic information to each
other they make these little lipid and
filled sacs that have DNA or RNA in them
and they shoot those out basically and
that's one of the ways that cells
communicate with each other within an
organism and even a cross organism
boundaries and even across species or
Kingdom boundaries it's like this
genetic communication system and viruses
are almost identical to these exosomes
to the point where it gets hard to tell
our virus is simply hijacking this
cellular machinery that can create these
extracellular vesicles or are they
themselves a means of communication and
is there some kind of
evolutionary possibility here with each
new pandemic that visits humanity like
is it part of our genetic evolution and
part of maybe some other form of
evolution as well a collective
initiation that we're going through and
this is you know very speculative but
when we open up our minds to a worldview
that isn't us versus them we're able to
entertain such ideas and I don't know if
it's true or not but I think that this
way of thinking needs to be on the table
and it will become on the table as our
technologies of control become more and
more useless to deal with the real
problems that we face today hmm yeah
that's an interesting perspective I
would imagine a challenging one you know
I want to be sensitive to anybody who's
listening to this who is sick or has a
loved one that's sick I mean at the same
time this is a very serious problem and
people are dying and becoming very ill
and there's a lot of fear in the macro
sense like telescoping out and looking
at it from that perspective you know I
imagine there's there's truth in that
but it's not a self to the you know the
wound that people are feeling at the
moment
yeah it's can comfort if you're the one
sick or your loved one is sick and we
have to take in all the data points and
some of the alternative ones and the
conspiracy ones this is you know
manufactured crisis to fulfill a
totalitarian wish list and so forth like
that leaves out data points as well like
the data points of there are people
dying there are people there something
is happening there is a new disease or
way more people who are getting the
shortness of breath and pneumonia and
something's happening and and and I'm
just one thing that disturbs me and I
mentioned in the essay is just people's
willingness to exclude data points that
don't fit their narrative mm-hm and that
don't fit their worldview and don't fit
their political identification mm-hmm
because I think that it's not only the
alternative people on the conspiracy
who do that I think the mainstream does
that too on an institutional level and
it has gone down a blind alley as well
and that the truth of this all if we
ever know what it is is gonna be beyond
what anyone can even imagine right now
allow me this moment of indulgence to
tell you about athletic greens
nobody maintains an absolutely perfect
diet 100% of the time so it's important
to have a convenient nutritional
insurance policy to ensure your body is
getting the essentials it needs on the
daily I've experimented with literally
hundreds of superfood supplement
products over the years most are just
one and done for me but I gotta say that
for a couple important reasons athletic
greens ultimate daily formula has really
stood the test of time and become a
critical component of my everyday
regimen one it's super convenient I keep
the travel packs in my car in my
backpack and in my office so I always
have a healthy co2 second it tastes damn
good three it dissolves super easy and
you don't have to combine it with
anything but most importantly it's an
all-in-one superfood powerhouse replete
with all the essential vitamins and
minerals 75 different Whole Foods
sourced ingredients scientifically
designed to not only improve immunity
but also increase energy support gut
health and maximize recovery
everything is sustainably sourced
there's nothing artificial no harmful
ingredients it's vegan gluten free dairy
free no added sugar just all the good
stuff if you're in the US Canada the UK
or Europe listen up you can get 20 free
travel packs valued at $79 with your
first purchase at athletic greens com
forward slash rich roll that's athletic
greens calm Ford / rich roll take your
nutrition to the next level with
athletic greens and finally we're
brought to you today by outer known your
opportunity to support a good company
doing right by people and the planet
with the coolest most ethically and
durably made sustainable staple duds on
the planet I'm talking about
climate-controlled t-shirts made from
organic pima cotton
from Peru and my personal favorite there
se a jeans which are incredibly
comfortable and made in the world's
cleanest denim Factory
how about for the ladies we got Airy
artisan textile dresses groovy white
organic cotton overalls and super
flattering high-rise filled pants but
what I love most about outturn own is
they don't sacrifice estate ability for
style founded by pro surfer Kelly Slater
outturn own is breaking the paradigm of
fast fashion pollution consciously
crafting their wares and some of the
cleanest factories in the world by folks
who are paid fair living wages as it
should be so tread lightly this spring
and some planet-friendly
essentials from outturn own go to adorn
own calm and enter my code rich roll a
check out and you'll get 25% off your
full price order that's outturn own oh
you ter KN Oh wnd.com
check out their super cool selection of
sustainable men's and women's apparel
and don't forget the promo code rich
roll for 25% off okay back to the show I
think beyond the the virus itself it's
really pulled the veil on the fragility
of our systems economic and political
you know the fact that everything has
ground to a halt and our economy is
basically frozen in time at the moment
and in essentially freefall and we're
now seeing what happens when an economic
system that's premise thanh you know
carrying large loads of debt and you
know businesses that are overly
leveraged you know this is potentially
cataclysmic and could send us into a
depression at the very least a moment of
repression that we don't know how long
is going to last and it is opening up
the conversation about what a better
economic system would look like again
this is something that you spent a lot
of time thinking about you've written a
book sacred economics so how are you
thinking about this moment in the
context of your economic thinking yeah
it could go either way
just like on the medical level it could
go either way toward you know doubling
down on where we've already been going
and finally getting rid of all that
alternative and holistic stuff you know
or it could be like wow this wasn't
working let's try something really
different
why are we so vulnerable why is our
healthcare system so fragile
like we could go into this big reckoning
and housecleaning and reassessment of
everything all the way down to the
bottom
same thing with economics if nothing
changes if we just continue on the path
we've been on then this crisis is
accelerating a long existing trend of
concentration of wealth and the
destruction of small business and the
concentration of economic and political
power in fewer and fewer hands mm-hmm
because the crisis is decimating small
and medium-sized businesses so you know
the big ones can get bailed out they can
get supported by the government it's a
lot harder to do that for your you know
local movie theater or yoga studio or
whatever like people are getting along
okay without a lot of these small
businesses some of them will probably
come back but we're looking at massive
devastation for small businesses and the
self-employed even you know medium sized
businesses and everything that depends
on you know the brick and mortar world
like the local kinds of businesses so we
could see a
extension of this long-standing trend of
concentration of wealth people talk
about I you know with the stimulus
checks and stuff at universal basic
income this could be the start of a
universal basic income mm-hmm which
could be a wonderful thing or it could
be a terrible thing it could be well
sorry you can't get a job anymore unless
you're a part of a shrinking elite but
we'll give you your monthly pittance as
long as you do as you're told right and
you know don't misbehave and you know
where your ankle monitor to make sure
that your know your electronic hall-pass
to make sure you're not at some
unauthorized on the central place etc
etc you know and and so most people are
kind of on the dole except for a small
elite and they can't get off it because
the independent economy that's not
controlled by government and huge
corporations has been destroyed like we
can see that mm-hmm
or we could see analogously to a
holistic revival we could we could take
stock and say wow we don't want to keep
going down this road what do we do to
bring economic power back to the people
to redress the concentration of wealth
and that could go along the lines of and
this is a moment where we could take a
different path we could in
some form of a debt Jubilee debt
Forgiveness student loan forgiveness
refinancing mortgages at zero interest
there's many ways to bail out the
debtors rather than bailing out the
creditors and the banks and the large
institutions mm-hmm and I hope that and
this is one of the one of the things I'd
like to put you know onto the radar
is that we don't have to go back to
normal normal sucked normal was like a
road to hell things were getting worse
and worse for more and more people and
not just people but for the for
ecosystems for soil for water for the
whales for the elephants for the oceans
like we don't want to go back to normal
and now that normal has been interrupted
maybe we can make a conscious choice to
go in a different direction that's the
the gift and that's what makes it an
initiation yeah that's the gift yeah
that's yeah it is the initiation I mean
you've you've talked about and written
about yourself being somebody who who is
sort of you know always perceived that
just around the bend you know something
like this would be coming and it never
seemed to come and now here it is it's
you know this this moment in time that
is so unique and unprecedented and yet
rife with so much opportunity I mean the
argument certainly can be made that this
is the greatest opportunity for
consolidation of power and wealth you
know in our lifetime certainly and we're
seeing that happening right now and the
large corporations are going to get
their bailouts and there's going to be a
decimation of small businesses across
the board and if that scale tips too far
in that direction that becomes you know
a scenario in which revolt and
revolution becomes a potential reality
yes
short of that we're also seeing on the
other side indicia of this gift economy
we're having conversations about
universal basic income in a way we never
have we're seeing you know people on
social media just getting out there
venmo and sending money to people and
over tipping and and doing all of these
kind of you know engaging these
beautiful acts of humanity that are
casting a spotlight on the beautiful
aspects of what a different type of
system could produce that would bring us
together and cultivate that community
and eradicate some of the separation
that's you know like you said this is
all an accelerant of these trends and
things that are already you know
happening yes it's just being
exacerbated right now and that's allowed
us to have a heightened level of
attention and with that my hope is that
we can take stock of that and really
seize this moment where we're forced to
stop when we're in repose to
conceptualize this better system for all
yeah I I do see both of those things
happening on the one hand this outburst
of humanity solidarity this that's what
always happens when the confining
routines of normality waver were
dissolve Rebecca Solnit writes about
this so beautifully in her book a
paradise built in hell when when there's
an earthquake you know and there's a
flood when there's some natural disaster
that sweeps away the structures of
society it's not what one might expect
dog-eat-dog looting and chaos and the
strong preying on the weak ah it's
people getting together to take care of
each other whoever has you know some a
kerosene stove they set up an outdoor
kitchen and whoever has food brings the
food and people they start to take care
of each other this natural altruism and
community and solidarity
emerges and you realize that it's been
repressed all the time by our systems
and ideologies of separation but it's
always laying there waiting for its
moment to come back hmm and the
is such a moment as soon as normality
wavers people can act on their long
repressed impulse to live the lives that
we are in fact here to live which are
not to maximize self-interest that is a
substitute a bribe to keep us away from
the lives that we're really here to live
which our lives of service to life and
service to beauty and service to
something meaningful to us that's the
only meaningful life and the only full
life and to sell that off to mortgage
that to mere survival safety security
self-protection that is a poor bargain
that we make that leaves us feeling that
we didn't even live life you know
instead we lived the life we were paid
to live but what about my life mm-hmm
where I'm not afraid to die at least
yeah maybe I have that fear but there's
something more important so that gets
liberated in times like these and it's
also showing us when you take something
that's happening unconsciously and put
it starkly in front of your face by
showing us the extreme of it then the
unconscious choice becomes conscious hmm
and that's what we're seeing it's like
okay here's our destination here's where
we were gonna be going a world of
isolation of distancing of separation of
polarization of concentration of wealth
of no human contact of no community like
we've been silently helplessly
unconsciously moving toward that as if
it were an inevitability for a long time
and now it's like the alcoholic waking
up and his spouse has left him and and
he's in the hospital or something like
that and it's like wow this is taking me
to a bad place and it's so it's a moment
of reclaiming our sovereignty and our
collective ability to choose our future
rather than merely adapting
something that we see is inevitable and
what future will we choose it's being
shown us by precisely this humanity and
solidarity that is breaking through the
cracks in the system yeah that it's
showing us the future we could go to a
future where we're all in this together
where we understand that your well-being
and my well-being are connected and even
the well-being of other creatures and
that health and happiness and even real
wealth does not and cannot exist in
isolation but only in community and so
we can say yeah enough of this
trajectory of separation now is the time
to rejoin the community of humanity and
the rejoin the community of life that's
the the crossroads that we're at right
now to tell a new story I mean there is
a sort of deconstruction and death of
identity and ego and ambition right now
everybody's been you know sort of put in
the corner and told you're in timeout
you need to reflect on you know what
what got us to this point and that's
terrifying
to be told hey I know you have this plan
and you're trying to get this thing and
do you know do this project or make your
way in the world in a certain way and
all of that is now out the window for
pretty much everybody and what are we
going to do with this time and we can
really reframe this story there is such
a beautiful strain of hope I think and
possibility that can come out of this if
we leverage it properly but if we
instead resort to our devices and scroll
endlessly and stoke our dopamine with
you know the news feed whatever
information silo you know we prefer the
moment will lapse and it will be a new
normal but it won't be the normal of
greatest potential and possibility now
it'll be a new normal that's
an intensification of the Oldman right
in exacerbation of that yeah how do you
think about this in terms of the thought
that you've put into how we ponder
climate change because this is another
strain of your thinking that I want to
probe a little bit and you know part of
your thesis is this push to go beyond
our paradigm of optimism vers despair or
you know this polarized kind of dialogue
that we have about climate change and I
think your thinking around this is very
relevant to how we're thinking about
kovat yeah there's a lot of parallels
that I could draw I can just cherry-pick
a few of them one is the this reaction
pattern of finding one thing to blame
for a problem one thing that can then be
controlled which in the case of climate
change I mean with with kovat it's
obvious what that thing is it's a virus
if climate change it becomes carbon
dioxide or maybe you know greenhouse
gases and it becomes the one thing that
if we could just control that everything
will be fine which taps into this kind
of mechanical model of climate and of
the biosphere which i think is actually
dangerously inaccurate so in in my
climate book I say you know really the
planet is not a machine it's alive and
it's health depends on the health of its
organs the organs being ecosystems soil
forests wetlands coral reefs grasslands
I mean every ecosystem really and
species you know whales elephants even
our organs and even if you can't put a
good carbon number on say whales we know
from the Living Planet organs of gaia
perspective that if we decimate the
whales and
destroy these other organs in the planet
it's still gonna die of organ failure a
death of a million cuts even if we
somehow like cut down the Amazon but
offset that lost carbon sequestration
with solar panels and carbon sucking
machines and we breached the sky white
with sulfur aerosols to reflect sunlight
then things should be fine right because
according to the carbon numbers they're
fine but know that quantitative approach
that reductionistic approach commits the
same violence that any reductionism
commits which is that it leaves out all
of the things that are reduced away all
of the things that cannot be measured by
the numbers all of the things that don't
count which in the end turn out to be
the most important of all and that our I
won't say our salvation because this
gets to another thing but I will say
that a future in a beautiful living
planet in which we are fully alive it
depends on bringing the excluded things
back in the excluded not only the
excluded places and species and cultures
but also excluded
I don't know genders races excluded
parts of ourselves excluded parts of
reality all those things that were not
important in the age of reason they need
to be brought back in non-human beings
the understanding that we're not alone
here we are among other conscious sacred
beings on a sacred world all that has to
be brought in and when we bring those in
then we make choices that may correspond
to Carbon Reduction policy but don't
always correspond to that so often they
overlap like even one thing I say in the
book is even if carbon emissions weren't
a problem I still would oppose fracking
mountaintop removal tar sands excavation
pipelines and so forth because they also
spill oil and degrade ecosystems like to
drill for oil offshore you have to do
seismic surveys
of the continental shelf which involves
150 decibel explosions every 10 seconds
to map the geology which defens wails
and interferes with their global
communication network of these songs
that can be heard for hundreds of
kilometers that weave the ocean together
into a mind and also perhaps coordinate
the whales to transport nutrients from
their feeding grounds to their birthing
grounds and like whales are an organ of
the ocean they make the ocean alive by
feeding deep underwater and pooping on
the surface and and seeding plankton
growth and I mean the whole it's a
physiology so anyway that's that's one
of the themes that also applies to how
we I think should approach coronavirus
mm-hmm which is to understand that this
virus is part of an ecosystem like why
are we so susceptible to it and why are
we focusing on this one health condition
that is amenable to control when I mean
look at the hit the panic around it
compared to the utter lack of panic
around five million children a year
dying from malnutrition mm-hmm why are
we not radically changing our lifestyle
for that five million children like why
have we not been in an uproar saying oh
my god we have to stop whatever we're
doing we have to stop because five
million children are starving well I
think it goes to the point that you made
in the piece which is that something
like a virus is susceptible to the
control mechanisms right whereas issues
like homelessness the opioid crisis
mental health depression things like
this are much more ephemeral and
complicated they're not as amina below
reductionist solution and i think that
you know overall what you're talking
about
speaks to the sort of failures of
reductionism and what's challenging is
that is how you square that with the
fact that you know reductionism is at
the very core of the scientific method
and you know that reductionist approach
is how we've pursued science
traditionally and we've made tremendous
progress in doing so but it is at the
cost of fully understanding the holistic
nature of all things right and our
inability to grok that is what has led
us to this point by focusing narrowly we
miss the larger picture yeah and to the
extent that we're now in a crisis in
which we're being required to think more
broadly about the inner dependency of
all we don't really have a system set up
to deal with problems from that
perspective it goes just that deep you
know we could talk about Systems Theory
and holism and science and so forth like
science is actually undergoing a
metamorphosis just like everything else
but fundamentally science is the study
of the measurable if you can't measure
it it's not science and measurement is
inescapably a form of reductionism so
when we have a scientifically based
society where everybody up holds
scientific as the standard to strive for
scientific policy for example we want to
be scientific in our policies what that
means is that we ultimately what it
means is we base it on numbers so it's
quite understandable then this is part
of the tilt of the playing field that's
quite understandable that we will gear
public policy to minimize deaths or
minimize infections because those show
up in the numbers and we have a
scientific policy where as quality of
life that doesn't really show up in the
numbers you know if one person doesn't
have a
respirator or chooses not to go on a
respirator and dies surrounded by their
loved ones and says goodbye to them then
that is considered a worse outcome by
the numbers then if their lives are
prolonged for another month hooked up to
a machine that's breathing for them
behind glass in an ICU saying goodbye to
their friends and family on FaceTime
this is a an image I got from Lissa
Rankin MD who wrote up a piece on this
you know she's like do you really want
to go on a respirator like what are we
choosing here but you know that's an
extra month of life and possibly you'll
get better and you can get off the
respirator is it worth it
like whether somebody dies well is
invisible to our statistics and
therefore invisible to any policy
apparatus that's based on the numbers
and so you know we could extend this to
every realm not just Cove in nineteen
and then it brings up a tough question
if we don't want to and I'm not saying
always ignore numbers and you know
forget science and so forth
it has its proper domain and there are
things that are beyond its reach that
are important such as quality of life
how shall we live what's beautiful how
do we live in a beautiful way hospitals
cannot keep records and form statistics
on did the patient die well that's
beyond the reach of science probably
forever mm-hmm so this brings up the
question okay if we understand that yeah
this whole way of making decisions this
whole we have seen the world has limits
it has its proper domain but there are
other domains it has limits then how do
we make decisions that don't ignore and
discard science but that give it just
one seat in a larger circle that
question I do not have
a cut-and-dried answer for I don't have
an answer for it but I do know that it's
the right question to ask in these times
mm-hmm as people are sequestered in
their homes what are some suggestions
that you could give to people to engage
in this process of thinking more deeply
about themselves and their place in
culture and in the world and and
possibly the kind of changes that one
might entertain right now hmm
it really depends on who I'm talking to
you know yeah I mean look this is an
inside job it's a spiritual inquiry you
know and I think you know in thinking
about this for myself it's about really
doing an honest inventory of the
decisions that I've been making and the
choices that I've made about how to live
my life and what's serving me and what
isn't and what is in the interest of
myself and my families and the greater
good and if I'm left with one thing you
know I'm sitting here talking to you my
day-to-day is not that unchanged you
know like I can still do what I do and
I'm podcasting from home and people
aren't coming to my house but I'm still
able to pursue my living and for the
most part I'm kind of going about my day
as usual which is a privilege but has
also allowed me to more deeply reflect
on this kind of hermetic existence that
I've carved out for myself yet has left
me yearning for more community than I've
availed myself previously like that's
one thing that I'm thinking about yeah
you know I'm thinking right now if my
dear friend he's actually my ex-wife's
husband you know who he's a
working-class guy you know he's a
building maintenance guy you know for a
group of juvenile justice system schools
and things and you know he's been
furloughed like that their family like
they you know at the end of each month
have like $50 they live paycheck to
paycheck like tens of millions of other
people mm-hmm and for people like that
life has changed an awful lot and I
think it's insensitive to ask somebody
in that situation to be asking larger
questions that you know extend beyond
just mere survival at this point yeah
yeah so that's like what I'm saying it's
like what I would say does somebody you
know depends on their situation but I
think even for I mean for everybody it
is but especially for people who haven't
been affected with acute physical
privation and who maybe have something
to share I mean you mentioned the people
you know sharing on venmo and stuff and
it does bring up a choice for everybody
how do we would direct our energy and
resources of time of money of everything
that we have been gifted that allows us
to be givers in turn one response that
we've been seeing is hoarding how do I
make sure that I'll be okay even
whenever other people aren't that's the
mindset underneath hoarding or some of
the financial responses uh how do I make
money off this what's the best
investment strategy that'll preserve my
wealth same mindset how am I going to be
okay even if everybody else isn't to
think in that way is to align with the
most dystopian future that you can
imagine it's to participate in that
future it is even to summon that future
through our alignment with it saying
yeah that's what that's what I'm
choosing I will be part of that and we
have the other choice to the choice that
is based on the interbeing story the
story of interbeing the connected
relational self that says yeah
how can I help how can I act from my
knowledge that we're all in this
together
how can I inhabit an understanding that
I am here to give that I am here to
serve life not to martyr myself but if I
have more than I need then what can I do
with this that makes the world more
beautiful and that lights up that part
of me that knows that I am here for
something bigger than just surviving hmm
and that choice is available I would
even say
not just to the privileged but I'm
thinking of Victor Frankel's stories of
concentration camps
he wrote that there were those in the
camps he said that would go from Hut to
Hut comforting others and giving away
their last piece of bread and he said
they were there weren't a lot of those
people but they proved that everything
can be taken from somebody except for
their power to respond to circumstances
the power to choose and that choice
comes from who we know ourselves to be
and who we want to become and yeah that
choice is conditioned by our trauma by
our circumstances yet there is still an
atom of choice that is inextinguishable
that becomes apparent it's buried most
of the time but it rises to the surface
in extraordinary circumstances when
normal has fallen apart and our usual
conditioning no longer applies we get
these golden moments these choice points
that have incredible potency to to write
the story of the rest of our lives
they're like these leverage points these
fulcrums that have huge influence
decades in the future for ourselves and
for the world so what I would tell
people is to treasure this time and know
that your choices that had been
invisible before but now our are offered
to you consciously that these have a
magnified power to change individual and
collective reality and so to treasure
these and to look for the opportunities
that will be increasingly presented to
us the more we orient to them the
opportunities as Fred Rogers would have
said to to be a helper hmm it's just
that simple to be a help
that's the opportunity that's available
to us now mm-hmm I think we'd all like
to have Fred Rogers around right now yes
it is interesting how we see these
things in the extreme right now from the
hoarder who is making off with all the
toilet paper to you know the giver the
extreme giver it's highlighting those
polarities of humanity in a very
interesting way and I hope you know I am
optimistic that we are in a moment that
we can really capitalize on to reimagine
a different kind of future a more
balanced giving heart based holistic
sustainable system of economics and
politics and social interaction that
will create a better future for our
children and children's children maybe
so and what is your instinct telling you
I think that anything is possible right
now I don't think that kovat has come to
rescue us mm-hmm I think I don't know I
I cycle back and forth through hope and
despondency and spending more of my time
in uncertainty then either hope where
despondency mm-hmm
and I see that we are standing at a
crossroads at a at a place where where
the road that we've been on is ended and
now it's radiating out into the future
100 paths or are before us mediating out
into the future and
Oh No like it's almost like we've taken
a step or two down the wrong path down
the path that points in the same
direction that the road that we've been
on has taken us mm-hmm and it's not too
late to just step over onto another path
it's right there and we can see it still
through the fog we can see see it in the
form of these of the helpers of the
Solidarity of the suppressed but wanting
to break loose ah holistic paradigms the
new economics the economics of gift the
economics of solidarity all of these
things that are that are just bubbling
under the surface that future is
available to us too but I don't know
like this it I mean I don't
neither of these futures are or gained
or inevitable
we are indeed at a moment of choice
mm-hmm which means that any prediction
that I make is a guess and that doesn't
mean that we're helpless it's the
opposite it's
we have a choice so the future that's
going to happen depends on what we
choose and they're in a mysterious way
none of us are the helpless victims of
the choice of everybody else and this is
where it gets really mystical it's not
like well okay I'll choose the world of
gift and the world of solidarity and the
world of we're in this together and the
beautiful world and healed ecosystem
I'll choose that but you know it doesn't
seem like everybody else is so what does
it matter that despair is built on the
same story of self that our ecocidal
civilization is built on it's built on
the same story of self that upholds
survival and the denial of death as the
highest goal the story of a separate
self that is therefore powerless to
affect the world unless you have an
awful lot of force under your command so
that you can dominate all those others
then you're powerful in the story of
separation but intuitively we can also
tap into another theory of change that
doesn't depend on force and that
recognizes our felt intuition that
certain choices in certain moments in
life have cosmic significance that no
choice is ever wasted and that our inner
world and our private choices are
mysteriously intimately connected to the
outer world mmm and this is a paradox
like if the future that we will
experience Co resonates with Who I am
choosing to be and the choices I am
making and the healing that I've that
I've been given well and that's true for
somebody else too and if they're
choosing a different one than I am then
how does that work you know like the the
the mind of separation cannot grasp the
power that we feel and know is inherent
in our choices
I like that it's beautifully put it's
sort of a theory of quantum agency on
some level right and it's empowering
right this idea that even when no one's
looking and this sense of disempowerment
that we all feel because of this system
in which we find ourselves
needs to be rethought and to understand
that the thoughts that we entertain and
the decisions that we make although
seemingly irrelevant in an infinite sea
of possibilities actually do have weight
and meaning and valence right yeah
that's well put had some basically I'm
articulating the theory of morphic
resonance
you know Rupert Sheldrake's idea that
that any change that happens in one
place generates a field of change and
the same change starts happening other
places even if you didn't make it happen
with force you are shape shifting
reality into conformity with the change
that you've perpetrated in your life
through an act of kindness or generosity
or healing or love you're propagating a
field of generosity kindness healing and
love and it starts happening everywhere
else too but you didn't make it happen
it's like you're shifting into that
reality in which it is happening and and
I just want to say like that doesn't
mean that I'm saying okay so forget
about political change and social change
and just operate in the personal realm
it's that principle gets applied on
every level and and I am this was not an
escape from the collective realm like I
am talking about debt forgiveness and
things like that but how do we make that
happen you know we can talk about it but
really what I want to do is to invoke
its reality invoke its possibility to
name that it is possible so that we can
align with it in the same way that I'm
naming the felt knowledge that we carry
that our choices are significant
these are truths that can be spoken into
existence if they are in fact true
mm-hmm and I'm happy to see that it's
not just me you know a lot of people are
now speaking these these truths into
existence and I guess I would I would
have to you know in my roundabout way I
would have to say that I am hopeful
mm-hmm like we've got a chance we have a
possibility of walking that path to a
more beautiful world
we can choose its
live that future is alive yeah I think
that's a good place to put a pin in it I
mean this idea that it's a crossroads
and an opportunity for a shift and an
elevation of consciousness because
however the house and the Senate votes
on whatever bill is before it is really
just evidence of a collective conscious
awareness of a thing right and that
begins with our individual decisions and
behaviors and thoughts this is something
that we have control over in a world in
which we have very little control but it
is the one thing that we can do and to
the extent that we understand it's more
powerful than perhaps we we walk around
believing I think is the beginnings of
the change we want to see yeah yeah and
I I don't want to
load too much responsibility onto us you
know like yeah we do have control over
that and it's also true that our choices
are conditioned by our circumstances by
our trauma by our unmet needs and our
unhealed wounds and so to say well you
know I'm choosing it and so on so over
there they just didn't make that choice
that is not kind or compassionate mmmm
oh and and instead we might ask well why
didn't they make that choice
what are they choosing from and how can
I change the conditions from which they
are choosing but that still doesn't
invalidate that there is a choice and
that our dormant choice making apparatus
comes to life when we do receive new
information when a truth that had been
hidden becomes visible when a pattern
that had been unconscious becomes
conscious when we see that it's not
working anymore when we were shown where
we are going that we had not questioned
that it seemed just inevitable like when
we receive some kind of healing
we hear words that resonate with our
secret knowing like all of these things
change the conditions from which we
choose and offer us one of those golden
moments that I spoke of before so yeah I
just want to like make sure that this
isn't being received as you know some
big responsibility that you have to do
right mm-hmm but it's more of just an
invitation to notice that Wow a choice
is available to me right now and to
receive that opportunity with gratitude
and maybe even with a prayer that I will
receive what I need in order to choose
the more beautiful world my heart knows
is possible I think that's a great place
to end it thank you
that was wonderful I really appreciate
you sharing with me today it was very
meaningful and thank you for that yeah
thank you rich I appreciate your giving
me so much space you know to go on and
on and of course well that's one of the
things with with with like these these
remote platforms you have to be careful
of not talking over each other too much
yeah it makes it less of a conversation
and more of a back-and-forth but I was
more than happy to you know allow you
the space to think out loud and I
appreciate it my only regret being that
we didn't get to meet in person so I
hope that at some points when we're on
the other side of this we could make
that happen I'd love to have you share
in person with me at some point in the
future your key yeah yeah I would like
that too yeah thank you so in the
meantime everybody can learn more about
Charles by going to Charles eisen-steen
org you can read his essays watch his
videos you have courses there as well
you have a podcast a new and ancient
story people can find that wherever you
listen to podcasts is there anything
else you want to direct people towards
no not really you can just you know find
it all on the interwebs right and all
books and everything I'll link all that
up in the show notes so you can find
that on the episode page and with that
I'm gonna let you return to your life
Thank You Charles I appreciate it
yeah thanks rich all right take care
Thanks how'd that one land for you guys
how's your noodle doing is it bending my
hope is that you found this conversation
nourishing Charles is wise beyond his
years
truly a Yoda for our times and a total
gift to humanity if his words
reverberate 'add in your soul I
encourage you to give one of his many
books a read listen to Charles's podcast
a new and ancient story you can check
out the show notes for links and
resources to plum deeper including a
link to his amazing essay the coronation
and of course you can follow him on the
socials at Charles underscore
eisen-steen on instagram and at sea
eisen-steen on twitter if you'd like to
support the work we do here on the show
subscribe rate and comment on it on
Apple podcast Spotify and YouTube share
the show or your favorite episodes with
friends or on social media and you can
support us on patreon at rich WorldCom
forward slash donate I want to thank
everybody who helped put on today's show
Jason camiolo for audio engineering
production show notes and interstitial
music Blake Curtis and Margo Lubin who
typically video the show although today
our show was done remotely no video
although we'll put up the audio on
YouTube as an audio only
Jessica Miranda for graphics Ali Rogers
who typically does portraits but again
this was remote decay David Cohen for
advertiser relationships and theme music
as always by analemma thank you for the
love you guys I hope you are safe I hope
you are finding a way to navigate this
experience with grace and gratitude that
you are reaching out to your loved ones
staying socially connected in this
moment of physical distancing and that
you really take to heart
Charles's words today thanks for your
attention I appreciate you I love you
and I'll see you back here in a couple
days with another great episode until
then peace flats
[Music]
you